GOOD AFTERNOON RULES COMMITTEE
FOR MONDAY AUGUST TWENTY THIRD
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. OF
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDING OF TODAY'S
PROCEEDING IS BEING MADE IN IS
ALSO BEING TELEVISED MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ATTENDANCE HEARING
MUST WEAR A MASK AT ALL TIMES.
ATTENDEES MUST OFFER FRIEND
FROM CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS TO
SEARCH OR OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING
VIOLATIONS OF THESE RULES MAY
SUBJECT INDIVIDUAL TO REMOVAL
OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT PROCESS.
MR SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY HERE CUNNINGHAM
SENATE FLORA GIPSON HERE LI
LEVINE MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS
RUBIO WHO ARE HERE WEBER WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA IS OUR
EMOTIONAL DECISION MOVERS TO
MATHIS SECOND REVERSIBLE FOOD
WHILE A MISTER SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL COOLEY HI COREY I
CUNNINGHAM BENNETT FLORA.
GIPSON GIPSON HI LEAGUE LEVINE
LEVINE I MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS-
MATHIS HI RAMOS RUBIO RUBIO IV
APPROVED BY THE APPROVED BY
WEBER WEBER HI MOTION PASSES
MOTIONS PASSED AND THIS OF
RULES COMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHO.